tsa screened over 1.3 million passengers
on sunday
most since startup pandemic more than
3.3 million americans were screened over
the holiday weekend
the transportation security
administration tsa
you know it was the biggest sunday you
know biggest travel day
10 months you know stand still
um you know it's a far cry
from the 2.422 people that were screened
a year ago
but i tell you one point three kai can
you pull up the tsa
uh the numbers what do you think about
this thing going to be 1.37 i mean i
think it's
obviously a holiday season full when
you're
traveling my flight here from miami
yesterday was packed to dallas 100
likes i mean tom flies every week or so
right so like you're
yeah i mean you're you fly more than the
airport's dead but
dallas is a popular route so i think you
got a lot of people come here because
it's a hub and then you're
anywhere else but the airports are dead
and i'll just say that dallas airport
lax is dead
you know i think this is great the more
the merry i think this is saying that
people are making decisions for
themselves
you know the the number of covet cases
are up but i mean that doesn't mean
everybody has symptoms or is sick or is
dying from it so
hey at some point we have to resume some
sort of normalcy in this country
the sooner the better go to cases and
death go to cases and
that's to see what those numbers are
looking like well i'll tell you what
people were partying for new year's like
there was no
pandemic going on whatsoever man it's so
dead
and actually one of the um interesting
places i was at in south beach shout out
to joya if you ever go down to south
beach check this place out
outdoor venue amazing you pull up on
your boat i said to the owner
uh my buddy marco i said dude everyone
is here partying without a mask like
everyone what's up because we were both
in mass talking he goes yeah
they all had coveted throughout the
summer like all of them they're all here
partying now they're they're they're
you know they're they've had they all
had covered they all had covet
yeah over the summer this is the people
in the world now they're partying now
their partners have already had it
they already had it what do you call
that hurt
yeah it's called hurt immunity and at
first when the herd immunity concept
came out what did everybody say oh my
gosh how dare you this is the
but now people are buying into the
concept of hurt immunity getting people
saying oh he's already had it well
i don't know i don't know if like
they're thinking hurt immunity i think
in
they're just thinking all right i
already had it i'm not going to get it
again that's
part of it it's eventually you you just
have to know that eventually you could
get it
you know if you're healthy young doesn't
don't have as much as you're going to be
safe
and the percentage is right now death is
the lowest we've ever seen it so people
are sitting around saying okay
it's not as deadly as we thought it was
going to be well i think
listen and we don't need to go on a
whole diatribe about kovid i think
you know the game has changed when this
started out in
in march and they didn't really know
what was happening and even fauci was
like oh you don't need to wear a face
cases fluke cases 20 20 20 20 19.
like i think at first like in any
pandemic people start to panic what do i
do am i done am i gonna die
i think people as we clearly know here
in this office
you get it and there's a 99.999 percent
chance you're gonna you're gonna you're
gonna live you're gonna be okay you're
gonna you're gonna be all right
you might have a sore throat you might
lose some you know a couple week of work
or what have you right
but this is information that we didn't
know
six months ago when people were freaking
out so like when you hear something like
in
la they're shutting down outdoor dining
you're like what the [ __ ]
is that they're shutting down everything
you know it's big business for the media
the media is in business to scare the
[ __ ] out of people and that's all they
do i got so mad on new year's the la
times is the most
piece of crap worthless rag there is out
there before after midnight
um no this is before midnight yeah i
know tom
no the la times is so disappointing pat
you grew up reading the la times it was
a great
newspaper at one point pat's thinking
about buying the l.a since their new
ownership it changes
i get alerts from the la times here's
one here's on new year's eve please
don't go out tonight
stay home with champagne and the remote
how to celebrate new year's eve with tv
who is the la times to tell me or
anybody else on this planet what to do
you just said not scarface right there i
here's my biggest problem they act like
they care they don't get right so here's
my question buddy
did you stay in on that night there was
no place to go you didn't go
so you listened to new york times i
didn't i'm talking about both sides of
your mouth
over to a friend i'm not gonna listen to
your new york times but let's stay in
shonda let's not do anything no no
believe me we
i would have gone out if there was a
place to go but we did go over to some
friend's house hell yeah we did
hell yeah we went to our neighbor's
story is
very close to kai's heart so i had to
read the story because uh
washington yoga studio i know you uses
religious exemptions to avoid cronovirus
orders jim and fitness centers are not
allowed to open until january 11 of the
kova 19 restrictions the washington
state yoga studio is declining to comply
with state and local coronavirus
pandemic rules claiming it has religious
exemptions seattle's
haute yoga
one of the city's highest rated studios
is holding in-person classes despite
democratic governor jay inslee
recent extension of statewide
restrictions hot yoga
founder lee zakaria told newsweek she
was not
asserting sessions were religious
religious gatherings but said
that she believes her work is essential
and is saving people's
lives however religious centers may
continue to function at 25
capacity or 200 people in king city with
implementation of proper social
distancing and face covering
creative or creativity this reminds me
of what you say all the time when we
talk about gyms like what the hell are
you talking about
people need to exercise people need to
people need to sweat people need to be
healthy
so you hear you have kai's favorite
thing hot yoga and uh
you know they're using the religious
exemption i got no problem with it just
social distance six
six feet apart when you're doing your
stretching and your downward dogs go for
it
from number one that would be my message
to her number two be careful because
that washington
governor does not play have you seen
that story where they tell me don't play
no
they will personally go after you and
try to destroy your life if they want to
but
look it's going we are getting very
close for these small businesses to be
at utter code red of desperation we're
gonna see some crazy stuff happening
in the next few weeks and months and i
don't blame these people they have been
gutted they have been specifically
targeted and so and told
by governors in this country we don't
care about you we don't care what
happens to you
make no money you're saying small
businesses yes yes i'm saying that and
i'm saying gyms i'm saying restaurants
it's so
unfair what they're doing to them with
no none no evidence whatsoever so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye